jetzt haben wir aber erstmal in die
Ukraine Wladimir Putin der erinnert
nämlich jetzt eine Kriegstaktik was mit
modernen Raketen mit Panzern Kampfjets
und Artillerie nicht funktioniert hat
das versucht Putin jetzt in der Ukraine
mit einer Art Guerilla Taktik nämlich
mit diesen brutalen Kamikaze drohen die
plötzlich vom Himmel fallen und die
irgendwie auch so schwer zu bekämpfen
sind fast nicht von der ukrainische
Flugabwehr zu treffen ja und sie haben
vor allen Dingen ein Ziel in der Ukraine
und das macht es besonders perfide das
Ziel ist die Infrastruktur die
Elektrizität der Stromnetz die Energie
und die Wasserversorgung
Kamikaze Drohnen über der Ukraine diese
russischen Angriffe lassen mehr als 1100
Orte ohne Strom zurück der staatliche
Notfalldienst der Ukraine erklärt
gestern im Moment sind
1162 Orte von der Stromversorgung
abgeschnitten auch die kritische
Infrastruktur ist vor Putins Kamikaze
Drohnen nicht mehr sicher Machtwort von
Ukraine Präsident Woller domair selenski
er sieht keinen Gesprächsbedarf mehr mit
den Russen schreibt er auf Twitter eine
andere Art russischer Terroranschläge
Angriffe auf die ukrainische Energie und
kritische Infrastruktur seit dem 10
Oktober sind 30 Prozent der ukrainischen
Kraftwerke zerstört worden was zu
massiven Stromausfällen im ganzen Land
geführt hat kein Platz mehr für
Verhandlungen mit Putins Regime
die Lage im ganzen Land ist kritisch
sagt ein Sprecher des Präsidialamts in
Kiew am Dienstag
[Musik]
BILD-Reporter Björn Stritzel jetzt im
Südosten der Ukraine unterwegs schönen
guten Morgen Björn ja hinter diesem
gefährlichen Drohnenangriffen steckt er
Iran und der hat inzwischen sogar
Personal Militärberater in diesen Kampf
in diesen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
geschickt
also Gerüchte darüber dass iranisches
Personal diese Drohnenangriffe
unterstützt dass der Iran mit
Militärberatern vor Ort ist eben um dort
anzuleiten um dort aber auch selber zu
lernen was seine Waffen da in einem
solchen massenhaften Einsatz
anrichten um da selber noch
Verbesserungen dann daraus zu ziehen
solche Gerüchte gab es schon seit einer
Weile und ich habe gestern den den Chef
der Militärverwaltung von Kirchheim
Großstadt im Süden der Ukraine die auch
immer wieder von solchen
Drohnenangriffen bedroht ist danach
gefragt habe ihn nach den nach
iranischen Militärberatern gefragt und
hatte eigentlich nicht mit einer solch
offenen Antwort gerechnet aber er zeigte
dann mit einem Messer auf eine vor uns
liegende Karte und zeigte mir
tatsächlich auch den Ort von dem aus die
Iraner aus herausoperieren sollen und
bestätigte mir auch dass sie da dass er
das aus dass sie das aus mehr Fällen
erfahren haben weil natürlich diese
besetzten Orte in der in der Ukraine
sich dort immer auch noch Leute
aufhalten die mit denen die mit den
ukrainischen Behörden kooperieren die
dort tatsächlich auch Spionage betreiben
und dergleichen und insofern konnte
wahrscheinlich diese die Anwesenheit
dieser iranischen Militärberater und
eben diese gefährlichen iranischen
Kamikaze drohen die sehen wir hier
gerade noch mal werden wir miteinander
sprechen Björn wie kann man sich
schützen vor diesen Dingern eine besten
Fall sieht man die ja wenigstens noch
kurz vor er am Himmel das betrifft er
jetzt auch euren Schutz dort in der
Ukraine hat man dann noch Zeit sich
irgendwie in Sicherheit zu bringen
die sind ja
verhältnismäßig langsam also die haben
glaube ich eine marsch-geschwindigkeit
die kaum schneller ist als 150 maximal
glaube ich 200 km pro Stunde und
insofern nicht sie werden noch mal
langsamer wenn Sie ein Ziel ansteuern
aber natürlich ist der Gefechtskopf den
diese Drohnen transportieren 40
Kilogramm ungefähr erzeugt natürlich ein
Explosion die ja die nicht gerade gering
ist das Problem bei diesen Drohnen ist
die zu erkennen bevor sie bevor sie ja
ihr Ziel erreichen und dann noch
abzufangen die Fliegen relativ niedrig
und sind deshalb für das für das Radar
relativ schwer zu erkennen sind zwar
relativ laut auch aber der Chef der
Militärverwaltung erklärte mir das auch
da die Russen bzw Johanna eine
Möglichkeit gefunden haben die Fliegen
mit diesen Drohnen gezielt über Straßen
über Verkehrsstraßen um durch den
Autolärm sozusagen die eigenen Geräusche
zu unterdrücken oder bzw ja zu
verstecken und dort sich so unerkannt
ihrem Ziel nähern zu können und dann ist
eben das Problem dass diese Drohnen in
Massen auftreten das heißt selbst wenn
Großteil abgefangen wird so wie es ja
auch die Ukraine mutmaßlich getan hat in
den vergangenen Tagen also da wurden ja
auch immer Erfolgsraten also
abschlussraten von bis zu 70% gemeldet
es eben reicht wenn da einige
durchkommen und dann eben Schaden
anrichten und da sie sehr günstig
herzustellen sind ist natürlich auch
immer so eine Frage des Kosten Nutzens
was die was die Abwehr anbelangt also
wenn man eine solche Drohne die maximal
20.000 Euro wahrscheinlich kostet um das
vergleicht mit einer einzelnen Rakete
für ihre stee die kostet halt mehr als
das 20 mehr als das zehnfacher und da
stellt sich ja immer die Frage der
Verhältnismäßigkeit wobei da natürlich
dann auch wieder ist danach geht das
dass der Wert letztendlich dann zu
schützenden
über den Einsatz dieser gefährlichen
iranischen Drohnen im Krieg des Putin
Russland gegen die Ukraine danke dir
[Musik]